another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation no using  scp-159 to make your office impenetrable  scp-159 is a seemingly ordinary neon  sign reading open when the sign is  displayed in the window of a location  the moment it is unplugged from an  electrical source it renders the  building or room impossible to enter or  destroy using anything from hurricane  level winds to x-rays dr bride is not  allowed to borrow this sign for his  office no matter how much he promises to  keep it plugged in he does not want it  for aesthetic purposes or as he says to  let his colleagues know they are always  welcome he is in fact planning to unplug  it and cackle wildly as anyone tries to  open the door while yelling you can't  get me  we're not falling for that one again